[Music]
so Tim how many dishes do you think you
are very confident in creating or
cooking or whatever without a recipe oh
how many dishes [ __ ]
scrambled eggs one yeah valid peanut
butter and jelly with bacon - it's fine
it's fine
is that even a dish sandwiches dishes
set dude you crunchy peanut butter I I
can I will do can yeah oh no not yet no
you order that [ __ ] like a year we're
[ __ ] February you my peanut butter
pump is still not in the Vail the [ __ ]
is a peanut butters episode of JK news
but I do get frequent emails from this
man and I'm like I don't give a [ __ ]
give me the [ __ ] pump dude he's like
yeah I can make up peanut butter pump
only ordered Oh cuz girl your to go what
the email say like I know your way yeah
they say that and he'll be like well you
know we had another hiccup with the
manufactured respond back give me my
money back you son of a [ __ ] that's a
good invention though good news we got a
Pina got a pump oh it doesn't pump
peanut butter yet all you have to do is
get a big pump and put down on the
peanut butter jar and [ __ ] pump it
out doesn't I just pump the peanut
butter a penis shape pretty much that's
penis butter now yeah I see peanut
butter pour smegma yeah big yuck and
that's it yeah that's it just - I mean
[ __ ] yeah I thought you would know more
no I I know about food I know how to eat
food look I can I can finesse some [ __ ]
together can you make Thai cuisine no
none not one single dish now nah it
doesn't cook like I'm good at like
here's here's here's my my forte
alright taking leftover [ __ ] and turning
it in some new
[ __ ] that's really good the next day
that's my that's just called microwave
no no I put it on the pan and everything
sure
see but no no I don't really cook
doesn't talk something you make for
others though that's something you make
for yourself right I mean I feel like if
I made it for others they'd be like yo
this is fire do you feel judged when you
create something like when you cook
something yeah whenever I put [ __ ] on my
IG stories like guys look what I do my
leftovers they always want to send like
you know puke emojis replies I'm like
wait you have leftover pictures I've
never seen them be oh I'll do like
little like hey guys check out what I'm
doing my leftovers say so I'll take like
you know some leftover Thai food and
then add some [ __ ] whatever sauce to
it and put it in a tortilla and throw
some other like you know veggies in it
is crazy and people I was like gross or
something like that sounds gross and I
just chop it up and I started to fried
rice yeah like no but people will even
send me like puke emojis when I make
like peanut butter and jelly tortilla
wraps you know I'm saying well that
sounds good you're like you that's gross
I'm like it's just perfect it fits
basically bread but flag you know I get
when I see a tortilla extract a certain
flavor yeah and yeah y'all weird and
adding sweet to it [ __ ] with me folks
my head put some bacon in your peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches no I'm
telling you no [ __ ] on bro I'll do it
what you can't eat one beat a butter
jelly sandwich has bacon in it I'm
traditional
I like tradition Lyndsey Britain bacon
or crispy baked crispy Chris are you
talking me into here this fire to it
this is it's known as Elvis Presley's
favorite sandwich yes this was his [ __ ]
it's a peanut butter but that's why I
got so fat
we've been and banana and bacon yeah
yeah it's bacon and sometimes sometimes
are just a little honey on that little
manuka honey what's that
manuka honey it's just that type of
honey I just like the name you think
Elvis is making that sound she's like
come on come on
come on manuka honey yeah so a survey of
2,000 people the okay judges why is
Elvis such the authority on sandwiches
because he was fat but shouldn't we be
like what's Arnold Schwarzenegger
favorite sandwich no cuz he's ripped so
he doesn't oh good good probably like to
know his favorite hobby so it's every of
two thousand people found that when it
comes to their skills in the kitchen 37
percent have felt judged by others so
one in three people feel judged about
their cooking skills
I feel judged by my wife all the time I
[ __ ] heat up frozen chicken that's
all I do
that's all I can make and I add veggies
to it sometimes she's always like smells
like [ __ ]
why put it on I put it on the [ __ ]
like defrosted no I don't I don't
defrost that's probably like the hardest
piece of chicken in the world it's
actually pretty damn good I do it pretty
good I do pretty good
I had kyod cayenne pepper and I had a
lot of paprika to it seasoned it yes
because you know your people are
stereotypically known for not seasoning
wait wouldn't warm up the Cajuns I know
I'm saying it's like it says they're not
considered white white yeah those are
spicy lines with the ultra whites dude
the mega white is the Cajun that the
[ __ ] by you hover grab people on the
[ __ ] small fish yeah the [ __ ] they
fish with their hands exactly they catch
[ __ ] catfish with their head bare
hands
alligator how do you feel about that
stereotype that why people don't season
therefore I think it's horrible
I love it [ __ ] bring them on bring
bring on ever any joke always bring it's
something do you do you eat casserole oh
I haven't had in years but when I was a
kid it's like one of the main things we
hate you okay
meatloaf I love people all you never got
a TV dinner me love it's delicious I
love me love Oh BJ's has a bomb-ass
meatloaf it's like an organ meat loaf
it's so good but so people always say
why people eat casserole I've never had
like cast I don't know what casting so I
didn't know if that was a real zero mac
and cheese yeah it's like throwing peas
and tuna into mac and cheese and that's
a [ __ ] Castro interesting mix yeah
it's like a big pan of things with like
now you just throw it together it's like
white people's fried rice pretty much
you get the leftovers whatever you throw
it together they put it on yeah it came
from my prices are many leftovers either
so my mom would make like salmon or some
[ __ ] and then like the next day she's
throwing that salmon chunks and like
like like like [ __ ] it up and then
putting in mac and cheese with peas and
it's [ __ ] bomb actually it's pretty
good salmon Caspar oh yeah it's like a
tuna fish casual you got me thinking
about Big Mac fried rice not go online
Mac's awesome sounds good you guys are
crazy
one in five people think that they only
have one standout dish but they can whip
up without any recipe and 52% have had a
kitchen disaster to the point where they
need to scrap the whole thing and start
out scratch I got that yeah I did that
one time when I was trying to so one
thing I realized to not have people
judge your food you should at least
taste it first that's what I used to do
is I would I would just make it and I'm
like it's gonna be so good I'm like oh
[ __ ] this is [ __ ] salty I'm like oh
[ __ ]
but then now I taste it as I'm making it
and then so I'm like control it like
Isaac and I were making hamburgers
together and so he made his own and I
made my own Patty and I was like making
like a heart shape whatever and I was
using lorries to season it but I just
[ __ ] love Laurie so much that I I
just went a little too and you went that
he heavy yeah it was too crazy to the
point where I started biting into it I'm
like you can't even eat this this tastes
like you put your tongue in seasoning
yeah but not the good way yeah cuz I
would do that I would just eat [ __ ]
Laurie's off my hands what did you like
Lucas
I mean that's where I get it from them
to this day I'll order for it and eat it
oh good but since I've been tasting and
go oh it's missing this then it's better
better huh yeah it's been amazing it's
been really good dinners have been happy
again oh are you the Bart's the main
cook in the house yeah
Oh interesting are you like do you cook
at all a she's a she's a postman scanner
gal post made it in a minute oh really
huh yeah I bet one minute maybe do
people ever recognize y'all when you
post mates cuz that's like yeah yeah I
hate that because I feel like oh now
they know where I live
I don't mind cuz I'm like what are they
gonna do they know my husband has 65
guns and I got dogs and I make sure I
open the door so that my don't my one
dog we have dog so my dog so my dog
shows up yeah and then they're like well
the one that shows up and backs away
liberate our garage it's easier for them
like I'm thinking and I'm like you don't
have to walk down the whole ass hallway
from the street to our place you could
just drive down and I'll meet you at the
garage and then this one time we were
like pecking things up and I completely
forgot that we had ordered food and so
we left the garage door open cuz we were
messing like we were dealing with the
garage and he kept calling me and
calling me and calling me and I didn't
have my phone on me or my watch or
nothin so I didn't even know until we
hear a knock on the door which is like
to the living room door and I was like
what the [ __ ] who's that and then so we
open it and then it's the guy the
postman's guy giving us our food and
then he ends up because Casey got the
food and he was just like oh by the way
I really love your videos it was like oh
my god this guy was in our garage for
who knows how long and I'm like I feel
so bad we left him waiting there and I'm
like yeah bad customer and I and then he
who's a good fan to me tip do you take
them on yeah I did so but I still felt
like I matter how many doors he opened
up in the garage with underwear oh my
god
I'll open up the car door to sniff Asifa
Oh God yeah I know no just like damn but
anyway back to the survey here so the
top meals that people can make without a
recipe is eggs over-easy at 49%
oh I'll be flipping them shits - I don't
even [ __ ] that's a meal eyelid that [ __ ]
is a meal
yeah no one inside a balanced diet but
it's a meal yeah eggs over-easy that's
it
yes and then the next one at 44% is
poached eggs that's not easy complicated
I don't even know what it is I know how
do you make it I think do you put like
vinegar and not as vinegar vinegar in
water yeah and if they get in the water
you know the egg white yes disburses so
the vinegar keeps it clustered - yeah
he's actually yeah and then it stays
there or you put it in a canister so all
the egg whites come together you said
disease if I wanna get out of
restaurants too much holy water you
empty the egg yeah yeah you break it and
you put it in there well it's you know
what I always wanted
don't do it the the the McDonald's you
know that McDonald's metal rings
everything maybe make all that if you
just have that and put that on a pan and
if you need a [ __ ] circle egg for
some reason just pack it in if you don't
be dope if you have one of those
straight up tables those iron [ __ ]
flat iron I really hope you become a
billionaire man I want you to buy the
[ __ ] crazy
I don't even think you need to be nice
for that you're right I guess I was say
because I want him to buy all the crazy
well that's a hundred thousand air dude
Jill's got like a shitty backyard girl
she's like I wish I was a billionaire
[Laughter]
[Music]